today we have met once again at 27 to
discuss the state of play of
negotiations with the United Kingdom
today we discuss the procedure
concerning the relocation of the
European Medicines Agency and European
Banking Authority from the United
Kingdom to other EU member states a
substantial number of member states have
already expressed their interest to host
the agencies and the priority for the
eu27 remains to secure the least
disruptive outcome for the citizens
businesses and countries sector homogeny
I tear apart on a material
Kusum at no clear mortgage air dog
processes okay chanel desig negotiation
the Toyko prohibition accord cadre the
Delphic separate a little drastic second
in Sumida cava sorry dad d7 de negocios
oh so Logan is a solo second negotiation
so Destructoid a discussion declarative
timing the set negocio son kanuto the
anechoic received second superiority
Santa Rita de Tomaso her horizontal on a
on october espera Papa's a oaken say
doll Gojira as Ramallah Venice parallel
in no description through horoscope in
graffiti Horacio earlier today another
General Affairs Council meeting at 28
what cells to examine the draft
conclusions that EU leaders are expected
to endorse at this week's European
Council the draft conclusions
demonstrate that the EU and its
institutions are responding to the
challenges the European society is
facing hence we are seeing a focus on
climate change and digital Europe
together with other measures that are
significant to European citizens